why does mark harmon have a reduced role
in season 19 of ncis and what do his
cast mates really think of him ncis the
cbs police procedural drama is currently
in the middle of airing its 19th season
having first aired in 2003 the popular
series is nearing two full decades on
the air which is an impressive feat for
just about any television show created
by donald p belisario and don mcgill
ncis follows the major case response
team special agents of the naval
criminal investigative service in
washington dc for much of the show's run
the fictional team was led by
supervisory special agent leroy jethro
gibbs played by mark harmon who is
widely considered the face of the show
however in october 2021 the hollywood
reporter wrote that harmon would no
longer be working on the show as a
series regular with season 19 episode 4
acting as a conclusion to gibb's story
for now executive producer and
showrunner steven d binder said in a
statement as an executive producer and
dear friend mark continues to be an
integral part of the fabric of the show
so regarding the future of gibbs as long
time fans of the show may have noticed
over the years never count leroy jethro
gibbs out still harmon has exited the
series at least for the time being
leaving fans to reflect on his legacy
luckily for us tv insider gathered up
comments made about harmon by his ncis
co-stars in which they reveal what it
was like to work with him on the set of
the show naturally they all have good
things to say to start with david
mccallum who plays dr donald ducky
mallard credited harman with creating a
productive working environment mccallum
said in 2007 there was always a certain
degree of chaos at one point during the
series production but it's all gone now
mark was instrumental in putting our
house in order i really thank him for
that in 2009 co-star michael weatherly
who played senior field agent anthony
denozzo through season 13 complimented
harmon's onset behavior saying harman is
a very rare person in this business
because there's no assistant no
entourage mark is largely just a very
straightforward approachable calm
assertive guy he's not a people pleaser
in 2019 cody di pablo who joined in
season three as special agent zeva david
said of harmon we were always trying to
infuse scenes with different things try
something new mark has been here for
years and he's still bringing it even
those closest to harman recognized his
impressive professionalism harmon's
real-life wife paul dauber who played
marcy warren in later seasons raved
about harmon in 2021 saying mark is for
the best of everybody and everything his
ego does not extend he just wants it all
to work
we'll definitely all miss harmon's
on-screen presence in ncis just as his
co-stars will miss him both on and off
the screen being that leroy jethro gibbs
was the head of ncis major case response
team mark harmon was considered the lead
of the show as the lead actor on the
series harmon's role came with different
responsibilities than the other roles in
the cast sean murray who plays tim mcgee
told country living that mark harmon was
number one and explained we wouldn't be
here 16 years later if it wasn't for
harmon harmon is a very special
individual during an interview with
build cody dipoblo also revealed that
harmon was one of her mentors you know
he's a friend mentor you know he's uh
um he was always like a father figure to
me
referencing their characters she
explained obviously zeva and gibbs have
that but cody and mark have that as well
when it came to being the lead actor
michael weatherly relied on harmon's
advice when he got his own series lead
role on the cbs drama bull weatherly
told usa today it's been very
illuminating and given me a great deal
of insight and regard for what mark
harmon was doing all those years on ncis
when i was like how come he doesn't have
as much fun as the rest of us it's clear
that harman remains beloved by viewers
and cast members alike check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
tv shows are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]